trente mètres sous terre
il fait plus de 40 degrés dans des
galeries haute d'à peine 60 cm et large
d'un mètre cinquante
[Musique]
comme chaque jour une cinquantaine de
personnes est au travail
parmi ces mineurs certains auraient
plutôt l'âge d'être à l'école il y as
kumar 15 ans santos 16 ans le plus vieux
de la bande le plus expérimenté voilà
déjà deux ans qu'il travaille dans cet
enfer la telus à 13 ans il a quitté sa
famille pour travailler ici
pourquoi tu es venu ici pour le fric
mecque et combien de temps tu pense
rester travailler dans la mine trois ou
quatre ans je vais voir je veux gagner
un maximum d'argent et après je rentre
chez moi au nord-est de l'inde
c'est le meghalaya une région voisine du
népal et du bangladesh
ici le sous sol regorge de charbon et
les mines appartiennent à des
propriétaires privés
il y en aurait près de 15000
[Musique]
partout le long des routes des dépôts à
ciel ouvert stock l'immense production
qui sort quotidiennement des entrailles
de la terre
cinq cent mille tonnes par an dans cette
zone
les propriétaires des mines exploite une
main d'oeuvre bon marché des hommes des
femmes mais aussi des enfants venus des
états voisins
[Musique]
une mine c'est un trou béant creusé à
même la terre à coups d'explosifs tout
autour des petits campements où vivent
les mineurs et leurs familles
c'est là que loge lattes et sa bande
ils se partagent cette cabane un abri de
fortune qu'ils ont construit eux mêmes
ils ont voyagé 300 kilomètres venant du
népal ou de villages reculés pour
chercher la fortune ces mines sont pour
eux un eldorado
tous les trois sont issus de familles
nombreuses
très pauvre des paysans qui vit avec à
peine 2 euros par jour
mes premières fois où je suis rentré
dans les galeries
je pensais que la montagne allait
s'écrouler sur moi alors j'allais me
rassurer auprès des copains passent à
table dans ce lac est intrigué je me
disais ils n'ont pas peur alors pourquoi
moi je devrais avoir peur
après c'est une question d'habitude en
plus il ya très peu d'oxygène et
maintenant ça vous fait plus peur non
non on n'a plus peur
7 heures du matin c'est l'heure où tous
ceux qui descendent sous terre
convergent vers la mine les trois jeunes
adolescents doivent d'abord descendre
plusieurs minutes sur des échelles de
voix près glissante sans l'accord du
propriétaire
nous avons décidé d'entrer dans la mine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ils rejoignent qu'une équipe déjà au
travail
ce sont des adultes qui chargent une
benne pour remonter le charbon à la
surface
la petite bande elle doit s'enfoncer
beaucoup plus loin dans les entrailles
de la mine
circuler dans ces galeries est un
cauchemar l'oissu porte sur les parois
l'air est rare
ici les enfants sont les plus agiles
pour avancer dans ce labyrinthe où se
croisent en permanence les mineurs ils
vont parcourir plusieurs centaines de
mètres pour aller piocher des parois
encore vierge
doucement doucement vas y mollo
ouais je sais tu inquiète pas et si ça
s'écroule on est tous morts à quoi ça
sert de faire ça c'est pour sonder la
paroisse pour éviter les éboulements
ça peut s'effondrer à tout moment tu
sais vous est tout le temps en danger en
fait bien sûr le danger est permanent
là je te le dis il faut bouger tout de
suite ça s'écroule on s'en sortira pas
[Musique]
l'athée vient de repérer une fissure
dans la paroi
il faut vite bouger pour ne pas être
pris sous un éboulement
[Musique]
mais à force de creuser dans la roche
toute la montagne ça fais
c'est ça le danger de mort tu as vu
beaucoup de gens mourir depuis que tu es
là j'ai trois copains qui sont morts et
tu continue quand même à venir dans la
mine
qu'est ce que tu veux c'est comme ça la
mort viendra quand elle viendra je me
réussit ou ailleurs pour moi c'est
pareil ça me fait pas peur au bout d'une
heure d'un travail harassant ils peuvent
enfin chargé à ras bord le premier
chariot de la journée une centaine de
kilos de charbon
vous arrivez à remplir combien chariot
par jour bonne journée
environ une dizaine difficulté
supplémentaire dans ces boyaux étroits
gérer le passage de deux chariots qui se
font face
celui qui arrive avec un chariot plein
on lui laisse le passage il a la
priorité
[Musique]
attention attention
soûlard
chaque chariot qui sort est
comptabilisée par un contremaître
c'est à la quantité de charbon extrait
que les mineurs sont payés
comment ça fonctionne entre vous y est
on se partage l'argent entre nous si on
travaille à 2 par exemple et consorts
dit chariot dans la journée ça fait cinq
chariots par mineur 50 50
et chaque chariot nous rapporte 3 euros
dans une bonne journée sans tache et sa
bande peuvent gagner jusqu'à 15 euros
chacun le double du salaire moyen en
inde de l'argent qu'ils mettent de côté
pour eux et leur famille restée au pays
toutes les quatre heures la t100 tosh et
kumar remonte se reposer à la surface un
moment où ils redeviennent des ados
comme les autres avec des préoccupations
de l'orage j'ai envie de voir ma chérie
la chance la mienne au népal l'autre
jour j'ai failli pas la reconnaître
je vous jure on a dîné ensemble le
lendemain c'est à peine si je la
reconnais c'est pourquoi elle se
maquille trop quoi non c'est ses cheveux
elle change de couleur tout le temps
c'était une fois noir une fois bleus une
fois vers tu devrais laisser tomber
c'est pas une fille pour toi
l'irruption de cet homme interrompt la
discussion c'est le gérant de la mine un
et palais lui aussi c'est le système
local
chaque propriétaire de mines indien
engage un superviseur de la même
nationalité que les mineurs qui
travaillent c'est le seul moyen pour
gérer au quotidien des gens dont on ne
parle même pas la langue
surtout les plus jeunes
c'est le cas d'un le gérant il passe
très souvent sur veille et surveille la
production de la mine et c'est lui qui
distribue la paix il est gentil avec
vous et il ne se met jamais en colère
enfin quand il a trop bu s'énervant
surpris par la présence de notre caméra
l'homme disparaît sans nous adresser la
parole ni nous expulser des lieux
[Musique]
le lendemain il pleut à torrent dans le
campement quand la puis surgit la mine
ne fonctionne plus trop dangereux
impossible de descendre et que beaucoup
trop toutes les galeries sont inondés
ont pour est noyé on n'ira pas
aujourd'hui ça continue le toit va
s'effondrer avec toute cette flotte qui
rigole mais un jour ça va vraiment finir
par arriver pour se nourrir ils mangent
toujours la même chose
matin midi et soir du riz mélangé à de
la soupe de lentilles c'est le dal le
plat des pauvres à ton avis les enfants
de tournage en france ils font quoi ils
font croire
ils doivent étudier j'imagine et après
ils deviennent des gens importants
nous on travaille pour survivre les
études ça nous sert à rien tu ne
voudrais pas étudié c'est trop tard pour
moi j'ai pris l'habitude de travailler
dur ici on étudiant je vais pas gagner
d'argent au contraire je vais en
dépenser pour payer mes études
deux jeunes adolescents livrés à eux
mêmes officiellement le travail des
enfants est interdite en inde la
scolarité est même obligatoire dès l'âge
de 6 ans comment expliquer une telle
contradiction à xining la capitale de
l'état nous obtenons un rendez vous avec
le ministre des mines
est ce parce que le charbon représente
70 % de la richesse de la région
en tout cas sa réponse est édifiante
faire travailler des enfants est
interdit c'est la loi dans ce pays
donc ça n'existe pas non les enfants ne
travaillent pas dans ce pays du moins
officiellement et officieusement
vous savez il ya peut-être des enfants
qui jouent autour des mines donc mais en
aucun cas il n'y travaille surtout c'est
faux archi faux
ok ce n'est même pas la peine d'en
parler ça n'existe pas
face à ces propos révoltant une femme
n'a pas baissé les bras
elle s'appelle hasina elle a créé une
association il a 15 ans pour dénoncer
cette situation dans la région
elle n'est pas très populaire vous savez
quand vous venez déranger le business de
tous ces propriétaires de mines
vous créez des ennemis ils savent que
l'on va découvrir la face cachée du
système ne sommes pas trop menacés mais
tous ces gens réprouve le travail que
l'on fait chaque semaine
hassina va à la rencontre des familles
immigrées et recense des enfants qui
travaillent
son objectif créer une école pour les
scolariser
elle compte sur des dons venus de
l'étranger et sur sa force de persuasion
on est en train de tout organiser pour
que vous puissiez aller à l'école
ça vous dit toi tu veux y aller quoi
parle donc
et toi ça te dirais tu veux y aller non
non mais pourquoi tu veux pas j'ai pas
envie d'aller à l'école souvent il y a
des enfants qui ne veulent pas aller à
l'école mais qui aimeraient rentrer chez
eux
drôle car lorsqu'ils ont quitté leur
famille pour venir ici
ils s'imaginaient que ce serait facile
sautent ils se rendent vite compte que
la réalité bien différente
dans ce cas nous les aidons à rentrer
chez eux
lattes et ses amis n'ont jamais été
scolarisés ils ne savent ni lire ni
écrire
poussé à travailler en raison de leur
pauvreté
il leur sera difficile de faire marche
arrière s'oxyde bruce hills est quand
même à sortir des enfants des mines
c'est mon plus grand défi mais c'est
très difficile de les convaincre il faut
leur faire comprendre qu'ils doivent
partir d'ici
même s'ils gagnent beaucoup d'argent ce
sont des clopinettes comparé aux dangers
de ce travail
un danger que sont auch kumar eilat et
affrontent quotidiennement toujours là
ils sortiront 800 kg de charbon faut que
j'y retourne je vais remplir encore un
chariot et après je pourrais aller
manger dans cette région du nord de
l'inde
soixante dix mille enfants
travailleraient dans les mines de
charbon
[Musique]